and stamps here with Ryan Schubert we're
gonna talk about the twitch stream that
happened today with Rainbow six siege
now for those who don't know Rainbow six
siege is a ruby soft project that I
think what did it kill Patriots or some
previous project this is this is what
Patriots became yeah it is a game where
two professional military outfits
morally ambiguous Lee fight over a
soccer mom in a suburban Boston suburb
that sounds about right
alright so the game is is broken down
into one section two sections
do you want to give the rundown yeah so
the first phase is called the setup
phase and it's about one minute long and
that gives the attacking team or the
breaching team time to use their drones
to try and figure out where the
defending team is and then at the same
time the defending team is barricading
and choosing where they're gonna put
their hospital so after the preparation
phase then the teams take a vote
so the defending team votes on one of
two rooms or sorry on one of four rooms
they want to put the hostage in the
attacking team chooses one of two
deployment points so they're not
instantly shot to death upon approaching
the house and they can split up two if
they want so each of the two teams are
then essentially broken down into three
classes you got your guy with the it's
not rifle of the guy with the shotgun
and the guy with the SMG additionally
there's some specialty equipment like a
riot shield a defensive like metal
position and the portable piece of cover
portable piece of cover basically so
during the setup phase the there's a lot
of barricading going on players are
frantically either covering windows or
basically putting up what we assume are
reinforced walls that probably cannot be
breached right it wasn't clear from the
gameplay but it looked like that was the
idea it was that there was basically a
counter to a breaching charge the the
window covers though could just pretty
much be melee doubt and both teams
demonstrated yes now some of the things
that we did and did not see
what we did see a lot of was games were
won or lost by player communication it
was the wall from the garage to the
waiter the attacking team was constantly
talking it's like Counter Strike they
had names for all the rooms and when
somebody went down they would like talk
to each other about what room something
happened in like oh guy went down in the
bedroom and so they'd be telling each
other that same with the defending team
just it seemed like map memorization and
communication was the biggest part of
these of winning or losing these rounds
yeah this is one of those games that'll
take a while to you know a good you know
week after it drops to like get familiar
with all the environments before being
able to get to that level of
communication so a question that we also
had was you know the start of around why
didn't say it the defending team just
blow out all the walls and kill the
attacking team on their way in or like
why didn't the attacking team to shoot
up the whole house and just whatever
happens happens so we looked at the ammo
counts it turns out that on both sides
ammo was very limited in this build so
each each class had about 60 rounds of
ammunition that really only broke down
into two clips and you can burn through
two clips very very quickly in a
firefight anybody who's played a shooter
knows that
so speaking of shooters Ryan how do you
feel about this game overall so far I'm
optimistic going in I was a big fan of
Search and Destroy in Call of Duty and
also diffuse in battlefield so that kind
of single spawn tactical communication
based gameplay is I'm a fan of that and
I'm really excited for you know I've
said this over and over again when we've
been covering other shooters but I'm
really excited for a game that feels
like it's actually pushing technical
boundaries and for me the Destruction is
doing that the the ability to like
grapple anymore on the house and come
through any window or come through the
floor you know maybe even the ceiling I
think that's what gives these games
immense replayability is just trusting
players to do things that are
unpredictable
so Rainbow six siege is coming out in
2015 on ps4 Xbox one and PC stay tuned
to games but comm for more Rainbow six
siege coverage
you